Друзі, всім привіт! Ну що ж, настав час
поговорити про німців та їхні автівки. Пропоную у цій серії
розібратися, як з часом змінилося ставлення німців до своїх автомобілів
і взагалі чим є автівка у сучасній Німеччині.
Автомобільна промисловість сьогодні -
одна з ключових галузей економіки ФРН.
Перший автомобіль у світі з'явився саме в Німеччині
наприкінці 1870 років.
У часи "віртшафтсвундер" -
німецького економічного дива 50-60-х років,
коли країна стрімко відновлювалася після Другої світової,
автівка була символом соціального статусу і достатку.
Запитаємо у жителів Бонна
як вони ставляться до авто у 21-му столітті.
Це мій робочий звір. Як корова або кінь.
Засіб потрапляння з пункту А до пункту Б.
Взагалі це ніякий не символ статусу.
Видно, що вона брудна. На ній є іржа.
Автівка належала моїй матері. Мама захотіла нове авто і сказала:
забирай цю. Я відповіла: "Добре, з радістю!"
Я їжджу на ній щоранку на роботу,
забираю дітей, їду на спорт тощо.
Ми маємо цю автівку для виконання повсякденних справ,
також по роботі.  Для мене це не є символом статусу,
Моя автівка для мене значить багато,
бо я її використовую щодня.
Тут вісім сидінь, ми всієї родиною можемо подорожувати
або я вожу нею на екскурсії дітей
на своїй роботі у дитсадку.
У вихователя дистсадка Уве - дизельний мікроавтобус,
і він каже, що з рівнем викидів Євро 5,
який має його авто, вже заборонений в'їзд до центру низки німецьких міст,
підвищився податок і взагалі, за його словами, дизельна технологія відживає свій час.
Після дизельного скандалу 2015 року, коли з'ясувалося,
що фольксваген маніпулював результатами екологічних тестів,
німці засумнівалися у своїх улюблених дизельних двигунах.
Торік серед усіх поставлених на облік нових машин -
62 відсотки бензинові.
Частка дизельних за час скандалу скоротилася
на понад 15 відсотків - нині на них їздить кожен третій німець.
А тепер давайте з’їздимо до Східної Німеччини, в Саксонію
за 650 кілометрів від Бонна і дізнаємося,
чи відрізняється думка східних німців про їхні авто.
Тільки-но розганяєшся на автобані до 170-ти,
через постійні ремонти, звуження автобанів
і перемальовану жовту розмітку треба знову скидати швидкість.
Під час подорожі на власні очі пересвідчився
в організованості німецьких водіїв -
на шляху трапилася аварія, і у пробці всі вишикувалися,
щоб звільнити центральну смугу для рятувальників.
Утворюють реттунґсґассе - рятувальний коридор
Далі в’їжджаю у мальовниче містечко Велєн під Дрезденом.
Одразу впадає в око велика кількість
автівок "шкода" на подвір’ях, можливо, через близкість Чехії.
Ну що ж друзі, а тепер запитаю у мешканців містечка Велєн,
що у Саксонії, як вони ставляться до автомобілів.
Заїжджаю до приватного готелю, побудованого у 1844 році,
і прошу розмови з господарем Штефаном Реріхтом.
У нього бензинове авто.
Це Мерседес, йому вже майже 20 років.
Випущений у двотисячному році.
Це вірна конячка, надійна.
Для мене авто - це річ ужитку,
вона має функціонувати, як дриль або пральна машина.
А от такі маленькі речі, як іржа або подряпини, не мають значення.
З набагато більшим захопленням
Штефан демонструє свій електровелосипед.
Основний фах пана Реріхта -  мануальна терапія,
тож щодня шлях у 25 кілометрів до своєї клініки
у Дрезден і назад він долає не на машині,
а саме на електровелосипеді.
Тут же ж у Велєні на автобусній зупинці поговорив про авто
з користувачем громадського транспорту.
Він виявився берлінцем, що приїхав у Саксонію на вихідні.
Лише один з моїх друзів у Берліні має старий Опель Астра або щось таке.
Його фінанси дозволяють придбати набагато кращу машину,
але він цього не робить.
Бо для нього авто - це річ ужитку.
Мій друг дуже рідко їздить на своїй машині,
бо в Берліні у цьому немає потреби.
Дуже добре розвинений громадський транспорт
і є дві великі служби каршерингу.
Себастіан - типовий представник молодшого покоління,
для якого машини - це не необхідність, а радше фінансовий тягар,
який 90 відсотків часу простоює і вимагає постійних витрат
на ремонт, страховку, парковку та пальне.
Друзі, а ця синя коробочка на звичайному житловому будинку в Бонні -
пункт каршерингу. Дивіться, перед тим...
у спеціальній еппці на смартфоні я зарезервував
Форд Фієсту. Тепер в мене є картка - прикладаю -
далі - секретний код...
набрав код...
і - ящик розблоковано!
Ось ключ від моєї машини.
А якщо не встигнеш повернути машину вчасно, заплатиш штраф.
11.54, машину треба здати о 12, я встиг.
Студенти і молодь, що люблять подорожувати,
користуються також послугами сервісів на кшталт Бла-бла-кару,
коли за невеликі гроші або навіть безкоштовно водії беруть попутників.
Ще один аспект мого нинішнього дослідження - електрокари.
Уряд Німеччини ще у 2010-му проголосив за мету,
щоб до 2020 року на німецьких дорогах їздили мільйон електромобілів.
Та від досягнення такої амбітної мети
німці ще ой як далеко.
Тим не менше всі гіганти німецької автомпромисловості останнім часом
роблять ставку на електрокари,
в розробку яких були вкладені мільярди.
До речі, взірцем у Європі в питаннях електромобільності є Норвегія.
Тут у березні цього року електрокари
випередили за продажами автомобілі на бензині і дизелі.
Сталося це уперше не лише в Європі, але й у світі.
У Бонні і його околицях вже з'явилося
лизько трьох десятків зарядних станцій для електроавтівок.
Давайте запитаємо власників електрокарів,
чи задоволені вони своїм вибором.
Розанна Шюлер заряджає свою електроавтівку
прямо біля свого будинку, для цього у неї є
спеціальна розетка швидкої підзарядки.
Пані Шюлер демонструє просторий салон і багажник автівки,
що для неї як для матері дуже важливо.
Ми вирушаємо у тестову поїздку на її південнокорейській Кіа.
Я не витрачаю гроші на обслуговування цієї автівки.
Тут нема мастила, приводних ременів, ніякого зчеплення.
Ті запчастини, які у звичайних автівках є дорогими,
тут просто відсутні.
Як символ статусу авто я ніколи не розглядала.
Цікаво, що у чоловіка Розанни - Роберта Шюлера -
набагато менша автіка. Це також електричний Смарт.
Роберт демонструє, що у Смарта як для його розміру
досить місткий багажник, куди стануть два ящики пива.
Чоловік возить із собою кабель підзарядки, який підходить до звичайних розеток
Для мене передусім ішлося про екологічний аспект.
Я щодня проїжджаю 60 кілометрів.
І я замислився, що я конкретно можу зробити для довкілля, для майбутнього.
У мене є дитина, і я хочу залишити після себе планету,
на якій і далі можна буде жити.
А от такі мініелектрокари полюбляють німецькі пенсіонери.
Майстер-клас водіння демонструє власник автомайстерні у Бонні.
На цій автівці можна заїжджати до пішоходної зони,
до зон, де заборонено руху транспорту,
тобто туди, де легкова автівка просто не проїде.
Такі машинки я вперше побачив у Німеччині.
Їх виробляє австрійська компанія "Граф Карелло".
На них не потрібні права, бо їхня швидкість - лише 15 кілометрів на годину.
Автомайстерня Крістофа фон Цедтвітца ремонтує не лише мініелектрокари,
а й всі інші види автівок.
Логотипом СТО є герб родини фон Цедтвітц,
яка веде свій родовід ще із середніх віків.
Ця автомайстрня у Бонні працює вже 80 років.
Крістоф каже, що не лише керує персоналом, а й сам не проти замастити руки,
коли є цікава електротехнічна проблема.
У процесі спілкування з'ясовується, що він - затятий автолюбитель,
і його слабкість - олдтаймери. Спускаємося в гараж.
І ось він - Шевроле Корвет, випущений до 25-ої річниці моделі.
Ну що ж, друзі, настав час покататися на Корветі 1978 року.
До речі, це мій рік народження.
Пішов дощ, а дорожня ситуація не дозволяє зупинитися
і закріпити жорсткий дах.
Сподіваюсь, граду не буде!
А це град!!!
Наші пригоди продовжуються, ми зупинилися під деревом.
Машину б'є градом. Ми ставимо дах.
Розчищаю сидіння від граду, вмикаємо пічку -
час підсохнути і поговорити про олдаймери в Німеччині.
Для німців авто - це певною мірою символ статусу.
Це також свого роду капіталовкладення,
особливо коли йдеться про олдтаймери.
З олдтаймерами пов'язані певні спогади, особливо про часи молодості.
приміром, у мене.
Крістоф каже, що такий Корвет, як у нього, може коштувати
до 50 тисяч євро. Тож, такий олдтаймер
не соромно передати сину у спадок.
Під час спілкування з німцями про їхні автомобілі я зрозумів,
що для більшості машина - це передусім комфортний засіб пересування,
при чому дедалі більше людей звертають увагу на електромобілі.
А молодь й узагалі не приваблює ідея володіння власним авто,
а радше такі концепції, як каршеринг, ат інші екологічні рішення.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще б ви хотіли знати про Німеччину,
і я покажу це в наступній серії! Побачимося!